do you know do you know how to do cpr
yeah so i was a lifeguard so we
had to do it oh yeah that's right yeah
luckily i always i always stop those
little [ __ ] before they
stop breathing did you did you ever have
to like do it no god no no you don't
you you'd know which kids were gonna
drown right before they walked in 100
wow i wish i was joking how do you know
okay okay i might as well just tell
stories about being a lifeguard because
it's just so [ __ ] so many
so uh basically whilst i was working on
mcdonald's uh
i want to be a lifeguard because well i
could swim um
it's a good start i was a really strong
swimmer and there was a course that i
did that took about a week
um and it was really really weird have
to do because i had to sacrifice a week
of school vacation
so i only had one week and i spent it
learning how to be a lifeguard i paid
like 400 bucks
and then i couldn't get a job for like a
year and a half because they were all
like yeah you don't have experience
because i was like 17 right that catch
22. yeah right no they didn't hire me
but
eventually um because it paid really
well at the time mcdonald's paid me four
pounds 10 an hour which is this much in
dollars and
uh the lifeguarding paid nine pounds 10
an hour oh wow which
at the time that was that's that's a
minted job bro
it was yeah but yes the thing was you
had to have a week of training you'd pay
for it
it's a double shift at mcdonald's right
yeah and you know it was it's
on paper it looks like an easy ass job
because all you have to do is sit there
for 30 minutes and you get a 20 minute
break then you sit there for 30 minutes
you get 20 minute break and that was it
basically um
but when you're new they put you on the
at least mine did they put me on the
shift
where it was uh kids birthday parties
and like because my mom swam at that
pool and then they never put me on the
shift with the old people because old
people don't drown
old people no because they know their
limits yeah because they all go to the
swimming club
all the time and you know it's you know
they're not they're not going to and
apart from like freak accidents which
never happened and like people don't
drown in pools in the uk
the the year that i became a lifeguard
uh
zero people died from pools in the uk
that's good
so this doesn't happen why are you
laughing about it until i started the
job
but like okay so have you ever seen
those
floats that take up all the pool oh like
all the lanes and stuff
the whole pool it's like a big
inflatable i've never seen absolutely
i've seen them you've
never seen these you've seen these
mainly you never seen these
google it like it's like a picture on
screen literally they're these
massive kind of like total wipeout s
courses right that you can inflate
and they take up the whole pool and if
you fall off you fall in the water oh
that's
funny [ __ ] it it was when i was a kid i
i loved the kitty it sounds like a trash
day special waiting to happen isn't it
it's like yeah i imagine like a bouncy
house on water
that sounds fun as [ __ ] no dude it is
it's literally house imagine a total
wipeout obstacle course on water dude
it's bad it's
dude when i was 12 i love this [ __ ] can
we do that dude we can yeah
hell yeah yeah go back to the uk we'll
go and rent one so like you could um
basically for kids birthday parties
uh there'd be like a five or six year
old who'd rent it out now problem is
with kids birthday parties
is that not every parent thinks that
kids need to be taught how to swim
right right i think because parents
forget that kids need to be taught how
to swim yeah yeah because you just take
it for granted
so what ends up happening is obviously
it's a birthday party everyone invites
their whole class
now half the kids in the class don't
know how to swim yeah but they still
are invited and go anyway yeah so you
know what
i'd be sitting there on my my thing and
i can tell immediately which one of
these kids can't swim yeah they look
oh that looks like that [ __ ] what the
hell yeah so they'd be like uh
it'd be like a climbing thing and then
you have to go through pylons and
there's a slide
yeah now you could tell immediately when
you look at these kids which couldn't
swim they just had a look in their eyes
where they were like [ __ ]
i've never been in this before what do i
do and that's a
big like thing of water because they're
also you know
kids are like that thing where like most
kids have like a built-in
like danger system yeah with their life
yeah like it's like heights right kids
know
that they're scared of heights kids know
that water is like weird and scary
yeah and then the kids that run in it
right away and normally like they can
swim yeah yeah
yeah but so you'd be what you'd be doing
this thing right and there'd be kids
and then you'd see this kid i i'd you
just tell again you can tell he looks
he doesn't look confident right his
technique's poor you know
looking at the water really scared like
toe first right yeah yeah
yeah so they climb on this thing and
bear in mind it starts at the shallow
end and it goes to the deep end right
right where you get off
right and then we're talking like i
don't know like two meters deep yeah no
no more than that it's
like three meters five meters deep five
meters deep at the pool i worked out
that's pretty [ __ ] deep
for uh for a kid it's like these kids
these kids would just walk right and
then they'd get to the end of this
obstacle course
and you could see it that they were like
what do i do
everyone else is going down this slide
yeah and they're being you know they're
being
egged on by their friends and they just
go down the slide and they would just go
down
this is sync they just sink they didn't
come back up they just wouldn't come
back up
wait like two seconds just to like make
sure just to make sure they don't come
back up yeah
and then you have two choices you can
either jump in or you can get a really
long pole and like poke them with it
and hope they
well normally
don't if they don't swim and they just
sing which is like
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] go in so then i have
to go in and this should happen like
three or four times sometimes in like
one session [ __ ] hell because these
kids are just terrible and you i'd have
to i'd like i would
sometimes i would go and jump in i would
get a kid
yeah what are you doing stop don't go
near the deep end yeah and then he would
go
and he would go near it again and i feel
i'd blow the whistle back what are you
doing
and then i look away for a second i look
back he's at the deep end again jumps in
drowns again
i have to go in and get him and i tell
his parents off and his parents have a
go at me and complain to my manager
saying that it's not my place to tell
her what to teach her kids
and i'm like it's not my place i should
i could just let your kid drown huh
see what happens then she went like a
full carrying mode on me and tried to
get me fired
because i bollocked her in front of her
like well because you saved their kid
because i went i after i saved this kid
twice
i i held his hand and i was like come
where's your mom show me where your mum
is
and then we went to his mum where's your
mom
what are you doing i was like why are
you letting this kid
into this pool without any armbands or
anything and she's like
didn't have any floaties or anything
yeah why would that's what i thought why
didn't they have armbands yeah right you
know her reason was she was like i don't
want him to feel
like he's he's like you know the the
weird one the one who can't swim and i'm
like
but he is the one who can't slam that's
because he can't swim
he will [ __ ] drown do you understand
how this works
like i'm like did you ever teach him how
to swim no i'm like why are you letting
him do this this is really irresponsible
and then i just left and this was in
front of
all her friends because they had like a
viewing yeah and then she complained
saying i didn't need to do that in front
of all her friends it was really
inappropriate for me
i'm like i'm sorry but like how you saw
your kid drowned once and thought
i'll let him keep swimming yeah i'll let
him keep going that really pissed me off
i'm still really annoyed about that yeah
that's just funny i mean i just
that just sounds like bad parenting that
was terrible yeah
the people that stuff like they would
just let their kids unless the parent
was like [ __ ] i've been trying to get
rid of it
again the insurance plan yeah it's
really expensive you know
that's a really late abortion plan that
is
doesn't this look amazing dude and it
was like it was a really good job